hey apples wants to talk to sal go ahead
apples in colorado
hey now style have you seen the netflix
uh
show surviving death i've received about
20 emails to watch that and i plan to
i heard it's amazing fourth episode
should be called sal
because it's called signs from the dead
i think they devote a half hour to like
coins and nickels one lady had a
cardinal she said
if my mom's alive i want a cardinal to
come back and like a cardinal flute to
them so
i have news for you i've had five red
cardinals appear in front of me and what
do you think
is that meaning what does that mean yeah
it's just a spiritual sign that
things are good and you must do good you
must do well it's just uh
it's just a sign of goodness i associate
cardinals with
uh people who have passed on so my
grandparents passed on my friends have
passed on
let me ask you based on your beliefs
what isn't a sign
in other words is there anything normal
[Laughter]
everything around us basically is not a
sign
if you ask your spirit guides for a sign
it's just then if you believe and you
and you raise your vibrations and you
meditate and you
truly believe then you'll receive the
sign
a lot of people dismiss the signs
everything has a path everyone has to go
through things
the yin and yang in life there's goods
there's good there's bad
and you know what i'm hoping i love it i
hope you cut off your microphone right
now
so when you die you will be sending
signs too right
if i'm if i'm asked for if somebody
asked me for signs
yes i would absolutely send signs and by
the way they didn't ask him for us
today i didn't want to say this because
nobody would believe it but i did
text somebody at the show a picture
the day i talked about dimes i went to
the supermarket
i got out of my car and right
in the parking lot in front of my car
was a dime
and that time to me was a sign saying
hey don't let people
get in the way of your thoughts and your
beliefs we are here
and i never do that never never let
anyone get in the way of your thoughts
yeah please and always share them with
us can i give you a bit of advice
i would say let anyone possible
interfere with your thoughts
so that you don't have them that's what
i would say
that's my advice to you all right